من لندن ينضم الينا دكتور احمد عجاج استاذ
وباحث في العلاقات الدوليه مرحبا واهلا بك
دكتور احمد كيف تقيم الوضع الميداني يعني
الجبهه عادت واشتعلت بشكل واسع بين الروس
والاوكرانيين غير تبادل الاتهامات
والتصريحات هناك تهديد كان واضح بالامس من
بوتن بتصعيد
كثيف صحيح للاسف الشديد يعني بدايه هذا
العام حمل الكثير من الماسي سواء للروس
ولكر
لانها يبدو على انها حرب مدن يعني يضربون
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره مناطق في
اوكرانيا وترد اوكرانيا بنفس الطريقه لكن
الوضع العسكري لا يميل الى صالح
الاوكرانيين الان لان الروس يتقدمون في
هذه الحرب على الجبهات وان كان بشكل بطيء
ويبدو ان السبب بذلك ان الاوكران لم
يحصلوا على المساعدات الضروريه لهم لكي
يصمدوا او على الاقل يعني يردوا هذا
الهجوم الروسي لكن الامور مرشحه الى مزيد
من التصعيد والى مزيد من التعنت لان الروس
يبدو انهم شعروا انهم اقدر في الحرب على
البقاء والصمود ولهذا راينا الرئيس بوتين
يقول اننا مستعدون لوقف الحرب لكن ضمن
شروطنا وبنفس الوقت سمعنا ايضا الرئيس
جلسكي يقول اننا قادرون على الصمود وعلى
رد نقل المعركه الى روسيا وبهذا فان
الطرفين مصممان على متابعه الحرب وهذا
يعني مزيد من خسائر للطرفين طيب اليوم
برايك هل العالم يستطيع ان يتحمل عناء
الحرب ال القائمه هناك بين الروس
والاوكرانيين وتحديدا الاوروبيين
والامريكيين بما يدعمون اوكرانيا من سلاح
ومن عتاد في مقابل ما يحصل من غزه والدعم
الامريكي الكبير للجيش الاسرائيلي هناك
يعني صحيح يعني بالنسبه هذه الحرب مكلفه
لاوروبا ومكلفه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لان عليهم ان يمولها لان
اوكرانيا عاجزه
على الصمود في وجه يعني الهجوم الروسي من
دون الدعم الاوروبي لكن الاوروبيون لديهم
قرار استراتيجي واضح جدا انهم لن يسمحوا
لاوكرانيا ان تنهزم في هذاه الحرب لان ذلك
معناها ان شهيه الرئيس بوتين هم كما
يقولون ذلك ستكون اكثر وستمتد الى دول
اخرى وهذا سيعزز الحرب في اوروبا لذلك هم
الان يستعدون الى احتمال مجيء ترامب وكيف
يعوضون الدعم الامريكي بالدعم الاور
وهذا يعني ان الحرب امدها طويل وبالتالي
هي رساله ايضا للرئيس بوتين بانه اذا كنت
تعول على ضعف اوروبا وعدم قدرتها على
الصمود اذا ما تراجعت امريكا فان تقديراتك
خاطئه فنحن قادرون على الصمود لكن هذه
الرساله المرسله لا اعتقد انها ستكون قويه
لان اوروبا هي الاخرى مرشحه لانتخابات
برلمانيه وبالتالي هناك احزاب يمنيه لا
تحبس هذا الحرب وتعتبرها غير ضروريه
مما يعني ان الازمه ستكون كبيره على
اوكرانيا
مستقبلا شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المداخله
دكتور احمد عجاج كنت معنا من لندن